bitte schreiben sie sich das auf die
heute show kehrt zurück am 26 januar das
heißt fünf wochen keine sendung ihr
heuchler was was natürlich auch bedeutet
fünf wochen keine sendung dass die spd
in der zeit quasi unbeaufsichtigt ist ja
und vielleicht doch in die nächste große
rein schliddert deswegen wird jetzt auf
sicher jedes mitglied unseres heute
chansons den genossen noch einmal ins
gewissen reden auf seiner hat sebastian
dann caroli liebe ist für die wenn ihr
das schon wieder macht dann gehen alle
umfragen komplett in den keller
und was noch viel wichtiger ist dann
bleibt sigmar gabriel außenminister
dann werde die sie nie wieder los
natürlich rein spd vergesst endlich die
kripo und schließt euch der linkspartei
ein
wir sind fleisch vom selben fleisch
macht das jetzt kein als hätte es so
gewollt vorwärts immer rückwärts nimmer
handy nein habe ich nicht
also ich ja ich bin gern noch eine groko
ehrlich gesagt durfte denn dann bleibt
frau merkel ja kann einen mit meister
boston
ihr seid mal leise liebe spd habe von
meinem eigenen geld einen ausdrucks
tänzer engagiert der euch nun begleitet
von mir auf der blockflöte pantomimisch
darstellen wird was in der nächsten
gruppe mit euch passieren würde
was waren das für eine kunst scheiße
also ich habe was vorbereitet ich habe
dich geschrieben wird folgendermaßen
liebe spd
lasst es
und kuppe spd spd kuba ich habe euch
selber ein bild gemalt ja das ist ein
kätzchen das ganz traurig guckt weil ihr
vielleicht wieder in die groko geht
macht das nicht bitte genau macht das
nicht und wenn ihr das trotzdem macht
kommt vorbei und besser jeder einzelne
von alt in den glühwein mexiko
mit in den tod
wer nun wirklich
in der sache ja aber nicht in dem ton es
ist weihnachten so können wir doch das
jahr nicht beenden wir sagen ja nur wir
von der heute-show wünschen uns eine
minderheitsregierung
trier
die wünsche ich mir war
somit diskutieren auch mal verlieren
die spd bekam profi
niemand hat bock auf 9
für merkel wird neue zeigt sich auch an
was trauen anstatt nur themen zu klauen
und mit glück ist es dann endlich leid
trimenon minderheit
ja das wäre ein hof und anarchie
die groko wer fährt
auf den frieden und wenn ihr das nicht
wollt [ __ ] euch ins knie
und das würde damen und herren war die
heute show 2017 wir sehen uns wieder am
26 januar jetzt unbedingt dran bleiben
für den satirischen jahresrückblick
kollegen wie machst du gut und du bist
nächstes jahr zwischen abend lang